In the abstract version of the bank account application,
each time we wanted to know the bank balance,
we had to add up all the previous deposits and withdrawals.
And if you've done any kind of implementation out there,
you know that that screams for having some kind of temporary variable that holds
the intermediate results so you don't have add those all up every time.
So let's add that in as refinement to our to our spec.
That is we're going to add another level of refinement,
in which we're going to implement this particular optimization.
Okay, that will reduce the number of computation that we had to do,
at the expense of adding this temporary variable in.
For the class model itself, there's just one additional line.
And this is in the attribute box, and
it adds in a variable called runningTotal, which is an integer.